well is like I can't read it over there
right cut it would be discourteous to
turn around really behind me but do you
[ __ ] are you ready
after this election is over we've
obviously got huge issues to face in the
party and I believe we have to have very
fundamental party debates I hope
everybody can work together to achieve
that do you think that we need to
develop our economic strategy so we
actually have my suggestion of a
national investment bank that could help
to bring about the necessary investment
in infrastructure and housing and all
the crucial things that we need in this
country to promote economic development
is the question is we just aren't gone
from the screen we couldn't work
together after the election yeah your
advice how to work with you and of
course I've worked with everybody I'm a
very inclusive sort of chap and I will
hopefully you know be elected leader of
the Labour Party but I would work with
whoever is elected in this in this
contest because I believe our party is
the you know best champion of equality
and opportunity what is work with
joseline
joining a Shadow Cabinet know I've said
very straightforwardly I wouldn't not
the Jeremy or anybody else has offered
anybody in this contest jobs because
we're not taking a votes for granted
still a third of the people haven't
voted you know we're out to fight for
every last vote that we can get but I
don't agree with the policies that
Jeremy has put forward I don't believe
that the solution to jobs and growth in
this region is you know saying we should
realise barse ways of the economy or
print money or reopen the coal mines I
don't believe that's right and honestly
people are sick of people just you know
saying things they don't believe in no
none of you would believe me if I
suddenly back to all of those policies
but I will always work for the Labour
Party to put our principles into
practice but the fundamentals of this
don't change you know unless we regain
people's trust on the economy or with
their taxis we won't have a hope in hell
of winning in 2020 so that's it maybe is
it
me gently cool I think as your turn now
miss